Через повільне просування контрнаступу
та наближення зими зростає кількість голосів,
які закликають переглянути пріоритети України та шляхи їх досягнення.
У цьому спеціальному випуску Conflict Zone з Берлінського зовнішньополітичного форуму
до мене приєднується посол України в Німеччині Олексій Макеєв.
Чи наближається Україна до того, щоб бути змушеною розглядати жорсткі компроміси?
Пане посол Макеєв, ласкаво просимо до Conflict Zone.
Дякую за запрошення.
Контрнаступ має повільний прогрес,
і ви стикаєтеся з багатьма викликами,
включно з втомою від війни, про яку ми ще поговоримо.
Усе більше людей зважають на виклики.
Вони закликають переглянути безпосередні пріоритети та шляхи їх досягнення.
Наприклад, колишній генсек НАТО і багаторічний радник українських політиків
Андерс Фог Расмуссен запропонував Україні вступити до НАТО,
але без окупованих Росією територій. Що ви про це думаєте?
Я думаю, що всі абсолютно правильно говорять про те,
що найкраща гарантія безпеки для України
чи будь-якої європейської країни сьогодні -
це членство в НАТО і сильні збройні сили.
У нас є другий пункт, але немає першого.
І абсолютно зрозуміло, що для перемоги у цій війні
нам потрібно повернути наші території і наших людей, які...
Але що робити, якщо ви не можете отримати гарантії безпеки для всіх своїх територій?
Ми маємо звільнити території, а потім гарантією безпеки,
як ми це знаємо з євроатлантичної безпеки,
є членство в НАТО.
Отже, сьогодні немає кращої гарантії безпеки в Європі для німців,
голландців чи чехів, ніж членство в НАТО та сильні збройні сили.
Чи повинна Україна розглянути пропозицію Расмуссена,
чи повинні союзники по НАТО розглянути цю пропозицію?
Ні, ми не торгуємо своїми територіями.
Отже, це не те, що ви б розглядали.
Та тим часом існує так званий Київський безпековий договір.
Це передбачувані двосторонні домовленості щодо безпеки,
спрямовані на перехід до повноправного членства в НАТО.
Країни Великої сімки погодилися надати двосторонні гарантії,
але поки жодна з них не зробила цього повністю.
Якими ви бачите перспективи прискорення двосторонніх угод?
Зараз ведуться двосторонні переговори з низкою країн.
Нещодавно також відбувся перший раунд таких консультацій між Україною та Німеччиною.
Отже, ми в процесі.
І справді, Київський безпековий договір передбачає ці гарантії безпеки
на шляху України до НАТО - підтримку України зброєю,
фінансову допомогу та переконаність, що ми можемо виграти цю війну.
Але якщо говорити про терміни,
то один із аргументів Расмуссена полягає в тому,
що час дійсно має суттєве значення,
що ви не можете чекати, тому це, можливо, має відбутися протягом наступного року.
І я хотіла б підкреслити одну з причин цього,
оскільки ви стикаєтеся з проблемою хиткої підтримки
на політичному фронті як в ЄС, так і в Сполучених Штатах.
У ЄС, де ви працюєте послом, вже не всі країни підтримують Україну.
Наприклад Словаччина, яка колись була одним із ваших найбільших союзників,
припинить свою військову допомогу.
Угорщина блокує нове фінансування ЄС для війни.
Звичайно, ми чекаємо, щоб побачити, яким буде уряд Нідерландів і що вони будуть робити.
Наскільки тривожним є все це для вас, коли ви дивитеся на цю картину в ЄС?
І чи хвилюєтеся ви, що інші країни можуть відколотися?
Коли я, як дипломат, дивлюся на те, що роблять наші хлопці та дівчата на передовій,
то вважаю, що для нас, дипломатів,
абсолютно можливо мати справу з відповідними урядами,
які можуть бути скептичними.
І завойовувати серця й уми людей і політиків -
це моя робота тут, у Німеччині,
і робота моїх колег за кордоном, в Угорщині та Словаччині.
Я думаю, що сучасна Європа усвідомлює свою силу і важливість,
і свою роль у міжнародних відносинах.
Ми багато говорили про лідерство тут, на цьому форумі.
І це те, чого, я думаю, чекають українці,
які ведуть цю війну проти могутньої російської армії,
від провідних європейських країн, наприклад, від Німеччини.
Що ж, очікування - це одне.
А інше - це те, що насправді доставляється.
Тож давайте перейдемо до Сполучених Штатів,
оскільки підтримка США також перебуває на критичному етапі.
Президент Байден і міністр оборони Остін оголосили про збільшення
поставок зброї, але отримання пакетів допомоги через Конгрес було заблоковано.
У Білому домі заявили, що понад 90% затвердженого військового фінансування для України витрачено.
Наскільки ризиковані ці затримки в отриманні додаткового фінансування для України?
І чи є ризик, що ви можете почати відчувати це на полі бою?
З одного боку, я щасливий, що я посол у Німеччині і не маю справу зі Сполученими Штатами.
Але, з іншого боку, я з вами абсолютно згоден.
Якщо на секунду подумати, що кожен день,
проведений на цій війні, означає загибель десятків,
навіть сотень українських воїнів, то кожен день має значення.
І це також моє чітке послання всім тим, хто ухвалює рішення.
Думайте не про території, а про людей, військових і цивільних,
які щодня гинуть під російською окупацією.
Ваші політики казали, наскільки важливою є підтримка від ваших західних партнерів.
Що станеться, якщо Дональд Трамп або політик,
який поділяє його переконання,
виграє вибори наступного листопада?
Тому що в його партії, серед республіканців,
є група, яка виступає проти подальшої допомоги Україні.
Це справжня проблема.
Для вас це потенційна проблема, чи не так?
Тому що Трамп продемонстрував близькість, наприклад, до Росії,
і він не завжди був на боці вашої країни, чи не так?
Це американський народ вирішуватиме, хто буде керувати...
А якщо вони виберуть його чи когось, схожого на нього?
Я, на щастя, не посол у США.
Що б це означало для України?
Як ви готуєтеся до такої перспективи?
Але я знаю, що американці найбільше цінують свободу і демократію.
Це, до речі, основні американські цінності.
І це також основні європейські цінності.
І я сподіваюся, що широка підтримка у США цієї боротьби за демократію та свободу
також відобразиться на результатах виборів.
Наскільки високим ви бачите ризик того, що ваші партнери
не зможуть встигати за потребами України?
Ну, з того, що я почув від німецьких колег,
і з того, що я чую від своїх колег, дипломатів і послів
України в різних країнах, підтримка не зменшиться.
Мені дзвонили мої колеги з Міноборони,
міністр закордонних справ Німеччини,
і казали: "Ми будемо вас підтримувати і надалі.
Дивіться цифри в бюджеті міністерства оборони Німеччини
на наступний рік для підтримки України - вони подвоїлися".
І це правильно.
Я згоден, ми всі, не тільки наші партнери,
стикаємося з проблемами боєприпасів,
нестачі систем ППО, тому що я можу порахувати всі ці системи.
Лише уявіть: якби я був таким собі начальником штабу,
де я мав би розмістити ті 5-6 систем ППО,
які ми отримали з Німеччини?
Де місце для приблизно 50 самохідних зенітних установок Gepard,
щоб захистити критично важливу інфраструктуру,
яку щодня обстрілюють росіяни,
або для захисту наших військ?
Ось чому ми закликаємо дати нам зброю -
щоб захищати міста і війська та наступати.
А для наступу потрібна авіація,
потрібні бойові танки і БМП і, звичайно, артилерія.
Це війна, яка поєднує риси Першої світової війни
з її артилерійськими обстрілами
та "Третьої світової війни" з масовим використанням дронів і штучного інтелекту.
Ми чули від української адміністрації,
що одним із найбільших пріоритетів є збільшення власного виробництва зброї та обладнання.
Розкажіть, чому це так важливо
і як швидко ви можете це зробити, щоб справді змінити ситуацію?
Тому що нам потрібно переглянути спосіб виробництва зброї.
Наприклад, під час звичайної доставки системи ППО клієнтам дають кілька ракет.
Тому ту кількість ракет, яку доставляють у мирний час,
ми використовуємо протягом 1-2 днів.
Це означає, що якщо ми отримаємо систему Patriot
або систему IRIS-T під час війни,
вона повинна бути забезпечена більшою кількістю ракет.
Те ж саме з танками і гаубицями.
Скільки снарядів вистрілюють з гаубиці в Німеччині у мирний час?
Ми вистрілюємо сотні за день.
Це інший підхід до системи виробництва і до технологій.
І тому ми запрошуємо виробників систем озброєння
з Німеччини та з усього світу, щоб розпочати дослідження,
розробку та локалізацію виробництва в Україні.
Це те місце, де потрібна зброя.
Тоді наведіть нам кілька конкретних прикладів типів контрактів,
які ви сподіваєтеся залучити та підписати,
бо ви спонукаєте ці спільні підприємства з компаніями
з усього світу до виробництва в Україні.
Оскільки ви підкреслили, що наступного тижня у Вашингтоні
відбудеться велика промислова конференція,
що ви хочете із цього отримати?
У нас був перший форум оборонної промисловості в Україні ще у вересні.
У жовтні міністр з питань стратегічних галузей промисловості Олександр Камишін
був у складі української делегації тут, у Берліні,
де зустрівся з представниками головних німецьких компаній.
І не виключено, що такий двосторонній форум
з українськими та німецькими оборонними компаніями
відбудеться пізніше цього або наступного року.
Але я гадаю, першою компанією, яка відкриє сервісний центр
з обслуговування бойової техніки в Україні, буде саме німецька.
Чому ці компанії прагнуть вести бізнес в Україні?
Адже є кілька серйозних перепон, пов'язаних з нарощуванням
внутрішнього виробництва в умовах виснажливої війни,
зокрема, з інвесторами, і це вважалося як одна з найсерйозніших перепон.
Крім того, їх непокоять вади в правовій системі
та корупція. Це, звісно, не ті проблеми,
які легко усунути, і вони були ще до війни.
Та ні. Коли спілкуєшся з німецьким бізнесом,
їх насамперед непокоїть безпека -
безпека приміщень, безпека персоналу.
Чому ж тоді вашому міністру фінансів вказували
на корупцію і вади правової системи -
це тоді, коли йому називали деякі з найбільших проблем,
озвучених цими компаніями.
Під час війни наше суспільство не має терпимості до корупції -
терпимість тут нульова.
Ось уявіть: щоранку українці прокидаються,
переглядають повідомлення про те, що системи ППО
збили російські ракети й безпілотники та й просто...
донатять кошти на ЗСУ.
Як ці люди сприймуть будь-які ознаки корупції в уряді?
Тобто хабарництво викорінюється,
за останні шість років ми створили вкрай ефективну
систему протидії корупції, що, до речі, отримало високу оцінку Євросоюзу
з точки зору підготовки України до надання нам статусу держави,
готової для початку переговорів про вступ до ЄС.
Гаразд, тоді скажіть мені, якщо поглянути на міноборони,
з вересня у вас новий міністр оборони, його попередник Олексій Резніков
дав кілька гучних обіцянок, тому що, коли йдеться,
зокрема, про корупцію, варто насамперед поглянути на це міністерство.
Лунали звинувачення у зловживаннях під час військових контрактів.
Це справді кинуло тінь на міноборони,
а ексміністр, який особисто не був до того причетний,
сказав, коли залишав свій пост,
що твердо вірить у можливість повернути відомству
надану передоплату зниклим постачальникам.
Ідеться про приблизно 980 мільйонів доларів за контрактами на зброю,
терміни виконання яких були не дотримані цього року.
Деякі передоплати за угодами щодо озброєння
просто зникли на закордонних рахунках дилерів.
Чи справді можна гарантувати, що все це вдасться залагодити?
Я вперше чую про закордонні рахунки. І знову ж таки...
Це згідно з повідомленнями, наданими парламенту.
І знову ж таки, наш уряд і новий міністр
змінили команду і впровадили нові механізми,
щоб усунути можливості для корупції
й посилити бажання оборонних компаній увійти в цей бізнес.
Вони, щиро кажучи, не розповідають нам про будь-які юридичні терміни,
проблеми чи звинувачення у корупції.
Ці компанії бачать тут не виклики,
а можливості допомогти нам створити орієнтовані на майбутнє сучасні Збройні сили України.
І це те, що нам потрібно. І багатьом європейським країнам це теж потрібно.
Я воліла б згадати й інші теми, бо, знаєте,
крім проблеми хабарництва, особливо в міноборони,
останнім часом також спостерігається чимало розбіжностей,
що набувають широкого суспільного розголосу,
зокрема, між вашими президентом і головнокомандувачем генералом Валерієм Залужним.
Залужний опублікував коментар, заявивши, що війна зайшла в глухий кут,
де визнав, що у вас немає істотної технологічної переваги,
щоб вийти з цього глухого кута.
Натомість Зеленський дуже публічно спростував це.
Такий публічний прояв незгоди між вашими головнокомандувачем
і президентом викликав подив, в тому числі у ваших партнерів на Заході.
Чи є підстави казати про ознаки розколу в верхах?
Звісно, це добра ознака дипломатії - завжди говорити в один голос.
Це - найефективніший спосіб спілкування.
Але, з усім тим, це теж свого роду демократія.
Ось дивіться, ми зіткнулися з величезною проблемою,
намагаючись переконати людей стримувати очікування щодо українського контрнаступу.
Отже, це було ще у березні, травні та червні цього року.
Тож нині є очікування, що ось-ось буде прорив українських сил.
Але якщо згадати...
Ми перейдемо до цього трохи згодом.
Але тут я воліла б поговорити про політику і керівництво,
тому що, знаєте, Зеленський, схоже,
публічно вишмагав генерала Залужного,
нагадавши йому про ієрархію і застерігши,
що військове керівництво країни не має займатися політикою.
Залужний, коли ми поглянемо на нього як на фігуру,
кадровий військовий, він надзвичайно популярний,
його розцінюють як потенційну загрозу Зеленському,
якщо він коли-небудь вирішить піти в політику.
Як гадаєте, Зеленський боїться цього?
Чи тут насправді розігрується саме такий сценарій?
Президент Зеленський - людина, яка ще на початку війни свідомо сказала:
"Мені не потрібно таксі - мені потрібні боєприпаси".
Тож, якщо ви думаєте, що українців можуть налякати якимось чином розбіжності,
які стали надбанням громадськості, то ні -
нас не лякають російські ракети,
нас не злякали російські війська на околицях Києва,
немає нічого, що могло б налякати українців.
Ось так воно, така реальність сьогодення.
Іноді мені здається, що ми працюємо по 25 годин на добу,
а президент Зеленський і генерал Залужний бачаться, я гадаю, кілька разів на день.
Повернімося ще раз до коментаря генерала Залужного,
його суті, яка полягала в такому:
Україна і Росія перебувають на фронті у глухому куті.
Ви згодні чи не згодні?
Ну, це може бути глухий кут на цей момент, але це не "цугцванг".
Офіс президента, однак, каже, що це, і я перефразую тут,
це був один з ударів у відповідь, який, по суті, грає на руку ворогу.
Дискусія грає на руку ворогові. Цілком можливо.
Або визнати, що ситуація, можливо, зайшла в глухий кут.
Але глухий кут не тому, що ми дискутуємо.
Глухий кут тому, що ми недостатньо озброєні.
Можливо, до глухого кута або замалого прогресу
призвело те, що ми отримали від наших партнерів трохи більше ніж 50 танків,
чи три системи IRIS-T з Німеччини, що є максимумом,
який Німеччина спромоглася б поставити протягом цих двох років.
Але, як я завжди кажу, просто розмістіть ці три системи з дальністю дії 40 кілометрів
на території України площею 600 тисяч кілометрів квадратних.
Така реальність.
Отже, одне з питань, яке лунало, коли ви говорили про те,
що відбувається на полі бою, полягає в тому,
що зрештою вам також потрібно більше живої сили.
Річ не тільки в постачаннях, які надходять від ваших західних партнерів,
і в тому, що ви намагалися налагодити самостійно,
вам довелося вдатися до призову.
Війна затягнулася.
Кажуть, що можливості для ротації військових на лінії зіткнення обмежені.
Є повідомлення про те, що дехто навіть ухиляється від мобілізації.
Відомо, що на цьому тижні Зеленський
має отримати низку пропозицій для поліпшення заходів мобілізації.
І мені просто цікаво, на вашу особисту думку,
як можна протидіяти втомі від війни й більше мотивувати
своїх громадян до того, що може виявитися тривалою війною?
Щоб зрозуміти це, вам потрібно поїхати в Україну.
Тому кожен раз, коли я повертаюся додому
або комунікую зі своїми друзями на передовій,
з українськими військовими, які проходять вишкіл тут, в Німеччині,
або з моїми батьками,
в Україні немає такого поняття як втома.
Але час від часу я бачу цю втому тут, у Німеччині.
Однак це не втома від війни, а радше від повідомлень ЗМІ про війну.
Знаєте, у часи, коли захищаєш свій будинок і свою сім'ю,
не можна просто відступити й сказати:
"Це забагато для мене".
Для України так багато поставлено на карту.
Це наша демократія. Це наша свобода. Це наше майбутнє.
Це те, за що ми боремося.
Вам доводиться протистояти країні, населення якої втричі перевищує ваше,
і час, здається, насправді не на вашому боці.
Мені просто цікаво, скажімо, коли розмовляєш з провідними політиками вашої країни,
то завжди чуєш, що мета полягає в тому, щоб повернути всю українську територію.
І це видається досить недвозначним.
Тож мене цікавить, наскільки особистою є така мета для вас,
і чи вважаєте ви її, як і раніше, реалістичною,
з огляду на всі проблеми, які ми згадали.
Як тільки задумуєшся не про території, а про людей,
то розумієш, що потрібно рухатися вперед.
Йдеться про мільйони й мільйони українців на окупованих територіях,
які чекають, коли українські солдати постукають у їхні двері
та скажуть: "Ви вільні, ми тут".
І на окупованих територіях замайорять українські прапори.
Йдеться про людей, за яких ми боремося.
І саме тому нам потрібно звільнити тих, хто перебуває в російській окупації з 2014 року,
в Криму і на Донбасі, і під окупацією росіян з лютого 2022 року, на півдні України.
Однак лунають твердження, що надії на те, що Україна
відвоює всю свою територію, схоже, тануть,
і що, можливо, Україні слід змістити акцент.
Я просто воліла б зачитати вам цитату.
Це Філіп Брідлав, генерал ВПС США у відставці та колишній командувач військ НАТО у Європі.
Він сказав наступне: "Ця війна закінчиться саме так, як цього хочуть західні політики".
Мається на увазі, що це справді залежить від підтримки Заходу.
Чи залежить успіх у певному сенсі від вас?
Чи розумієте ви, що, можливо, наступного року, в найближчі два роки,
в залежності від настрою, вашу країну можуть примусити піти на поступки?
Гадаю, чого нам бракує в багатьох країнах, так це готовності лідирувати.
Слово "лідерство" я чув сьогодні сто разів.
І це саме те, що нам потрібно - лідерство,
яке буде ухвалювати правильні рішення
і допомагати нам перемогти в цій війні
і виборювати повернення свободи й миру в Європу.
Пане посол Макеєв, щиро дякуємо вам за участь у програмі Conflict Zone.
Дякую й вам!